[Music]
congratulations on everything thank you
how does it feel to be here tonight
walking at the golden below you know
this movie was so fun to make it was
such a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
really I mean I I thought the old
Hollywood musical was dead not when you
guys are going to work on one was reward
enough you know so this is just it's
such a surprise really I mean I was
ready to to defend the film but the
response has been quite the opposite you
talk with Emma today I haven't I just we
were in opposite sides of the lion so it
look like she was leaving oh I doubt
she's leaving now maybe she's getting
ready to present her something great is
it even here tonight no she's at home
with our girls babysitting I don't
probably yelling through the TV when she
watches it tonight
Oh cheering Your Honor you're sitting
with Justin Timberlake instead of your
pretty wife other Justin's kind of
pretty
that's what I hear oh that's news to me
oh really you didn't know that I did not
know that
he's pretty jus not as pretty as your
wife no doesn't compare right so excited
about it
not really all right Justin lovely to
see you but certainly no comparison yeah
he'll understand everybody's make as
much to do about the Ryan against the
Ryan you know Ryan Gosling Ryan Reynolds
right now handsome very talented man
what'd you think about all that you know
I'm just happy that we're both in the
same room for once so people can see
there were different people and I'll
take that as a win
you